[Music]
the Higgs boson was a great discovery
the Higgs boson is a very special
particle very different from the other
elementary particles that had been
discovered before its role is special it
has the role of given mass to the other
elementary particles and so allowing
enable the fundamental constituents of
atoms to stick together because if the
constituents of atoms the electrons and
the quarks do not have a mass atoms will
not stick together so the Higgs boson is
a very special particle of course it
would have been very very nice to
discover other particles but the fact
that we have not yet discovered them I'm
saying yet because the Large Hadron
Collider has only delivered say less
than 10% of the ultimate amount of data
doesn't mean that this is a negative
thing on the contrary in physics in
science in research first of all
measurements of known particles and all
of known quantities are of primary
importance to make a step forward but
also being able to eliminate possible
theories or you know show the way to
move forward and this is made through
discovery but also through showing that
some particles that were expected are
actually not there
the larger atom Collider at the moment
is in shutdown for two years 2019 and
2020 we have this this shutdown periods
regularly to perform maintenance and
upgrade of the collider at the moment we
are upgrading some components of the
accelerator chain to be able to start
data taking an operation again in 2021
with more intense proton beams and so to
produce to be able to produce more
collisions and therefore to have larger
opportunities of measuring known
particles and also looking for real
phenomenon at the moment a CERN is
studying a future Collider a post
Aleksey Collider we are in a phase of
design studies and R&D of accelerator
components and we have two different
projects on the table 1 is a linear
collider smashing electrons and
positrons of a length between 11 and 50
kilometers depending on the and the
energy and increasing with time and the
other one is what we call future
circular Collider a hundred kilometer
ring so three times bigger than the
Large Hadron Collider both projects that
have not yet approved are very important
too
push our understanding of the Higgs
boson first of all the expose on is
still largely a very mysterious particle
and is in some way related to some open
question outstanding questions in our
understanding of fundamental physics
related for reason to the fate of our
universe is our universe stable or
metastable if it is metastable one day
it will collapse so it's very important
to get to know the Higgs boson much much
better than we know it today but also we
with these newer accelerators and
colliders we are going to also to
address outstanding question in particle
physics that matter is still a question
mark we don't know 25% of the matter
that of which the universe is made
understanding where the antimatter
disappear some point in these early
universe matter antimatter were before
in similar quantities you know you know
nature at some point decided to favor
matter over and antimatter
thank goodness otherwise will not be
here but still we don't understand why
now so this this is these instruments
will allow us to make a state drag
antics first step for in our
understanding of fundamental physics and
the universe they are expensive but
they're not going to be paid in a few
weeks the cost and the payment will be
extended over decades we are talking
about decades there is big international
competition for hosting the next big
Collider after the LHC Japan is thinking
of the linear collider and China is
taking 100 kilometer ring like the few
future silver collide
this testifies to the importance of
fundamental physics because if Japan and
China are interested in doing this big
you know acting building this big
accelerator it means that the science is
interesting and the technology that they
will allow develop are interesting why
do we want to have such a big Collider
at CERN so in Europe that's simply
because with CERN Europe over the past
60 years was able to bring back the
leadership in fundamental physics from
the US and other places in the world
back to Europe CERN was founded in the
aftermath of World War two with the goal
on one end to bring back scientific
excellence and leadership after the war
well you know many scientists had
migrated out of Europe and then of
course to learn to foster peaceful
collaboration across earth through
science over the past decades CERN has
gained this leadership and has the
ownership of the technologies of the
cutting edge technologies that such big
colliders requires and we have the
technologies we have the leadership it
will be a pity to lose it to some other
regions of the world
you